a hello and welcome between
midday meetings live on bs
today is monday february 21
as we did not see each other
friday i start with the agenda of the
presidency for this week
this wednesday the president will preside
starts at  usual the
college meeting then on wednesday afternoon she will
meet yonath guy you will have the
prime minister of norway
then i want to remind you of the two
meetings taking place
across the street today first the
commissioners ian  white things that
were there caryatids and virgin music and
vitus represents the committee in
the agriculture and fisheries council
today ministers will discuss among other things
the proposed regulation
on the export of products
associated with deforestation and
forest degradation means
to improve the coherence between
the european green deal, the common agricultural
policy and the trade policy
of the current situation d  u market for
certain agricultural products and
the future of the common
fisheries
policy commissioners grychowski the
commissioner during your thing who will
participate in a press conference
this evening around 8.30
p.m. valaisan joseph bourrel and
shoulders
the
action rally works and is a
territory in haiti
the
five days which weigh
heavily you have to believe it
and once is not custom I give
the floor to jean hello jean
hello can you hear me I
try as I give so yes I
imagine that we  you have read the article that
I devoted today to phil hogan
I have two questions or
to ask concerning the precisely there the
procedure when one pushes a commissioner
the resignation that one asks that one demands
his resignation is  what do you not think
that after this unfortunate affair
the show two girls the gall which follows
the unfounded resignation either
of the former Maltese commissioner under the
barroso commission it turned out that the
file was totally empty, it
would not be necessary to develop a
procedure which guarantees that the
presumption of innocence
is respected and that the commissioner who
is suspected of having violated his
obligations
can present his defense in particular,
for example, why not provide for
referral to the committee of  ethics which, it
seems to me, is there for that and which in
this case was not seized any
more than the college of commissioners
which is very surprising when faced with the same
question second question is what
would not have a double  standards applied
to commissioners depending on whether they are
supported or not by their capital in
this case phil hogan was more
supported by his capital by his
government which demanded his resignation
whereas we see that other
commissioners who are supported by their
capital uh no it's just no
problem I remind you
once again there are rooms that participate
in hunts or hobby dinners
list without the  s to declare has absolutely
no problem we have no explanation
considers that it is completely normal
it is true that his government is
behind him or even the
Hungarian commissioner olivères varini who
supports the separatists of the
seizure  Zionist rather of the republic
in certain cases without there being the slightest
consequence so there I would like us
to take when is a
commissioner at risk of being fired and
when can he go to the  beyond
the red lines, would it by chance
not be the support even
without this support from the national government
, which raises the real question of
the independence of the commission, thank
you, thank you very much, people for
questions regarding the second
question  answer is extremely simple I
can sum it up in one word in one word no
all this support as you say or
not of the capital does not play obviously plays
no role with regard to
your first question I take n  ote de
t2t suggestions I remind you that it was
commissioner hogan
who presented his resignation following
discussions with the president over a
period that
spanned several days and following
that there  had statements that
were published as I already said
last week not worth adding
to what was said at that time
people hold back follow up question
excuse me where i think i see able
highly others  people who
ask people to speak the show goes on 6 he's
got a lot of nice this mandate by
iso ku there I see a person that's
why
because I
would like I would still like to have a
clarification that's what you say  that there was
a series of meetings indeed
there were four meetings in three days
but the head of the legal department
actually in progress of this
decision-makers meeting of Wednesday August 27 August 26
sorry you were not present on the
other hand there was the  head of
legal department who was present and who
concluded that the law had not been violated
in this case so my request and I
make my request officially here
now there that I will send you a
mail later I would like to
have the  all the written
documents dishes text messages that the president
her communication adviser who seems to
have played an essential role in this
affair the masterpiece her chief of
staff the trawl legal scene would have
changed during these three days here
it is a request  official after the
decision of the NGO human events
I would like you to do so
here are my tokens want his written part
to support this request thank you thank you
Jean of course we will treat with
all the rigor
which is due to him the request for  access
to documents in this context
I am happy to see that you know who
and where they were who was at who was
not at meetings and what was
said or what  who does not  st not said there is
a rule which is extremely well kept
here on the podium and which you know
like me is that we do
not comment on meetings of internal meetings
but therefore I will
wait for the institution wait for your
written request access  for access to documents are
there any other questions on this subject
please keep your hands raised only
if it's on this subject virginie no
sorry I don't know
then virginie your question is she on
this case if yes go  -y otherwise I'll give the
floor to tony
not on that so when she comes
back next virginie to you tony
[Music]
circulation with just something like
yes
in intro meeting gérard fischer
statements of fame
commissioner son rogen a woman
president online explaining de  these
mosquito lodges
17 will have nothing can
in circulation monday 9 cindy
audo
formations said they would take
effect the andes
virginia sexy game on something else so
i guess not oliva and i believe i
don't hear skies
hes
so they organs rice also
motorized
from yzeure many times we live in 2000
tings tattoo crisis dalil
thank you did the president
ask mr robert to resign
it's the same question is in
another language I just answered
cities
david you want to ask another question
no you haven't just answered that's the
problem whereas the
commission spokesperson maybe you don't want to
answer but the question is  simple to
what the president asked
sir or to resign if you
do not want to answer your question but
I have already answered what I have already said
that he answered several times that
you had official declarations
time of the comice  and a son rogen and
the presidency on this subject and that we
had no further comments to
make
on the course of events and
I stick to this this line
michael has the question is on this subject
also
yes  I'm sorry  ie please from the memory
of journalist philippe rogen had
lost at that time all support from
the irish government to
represent ireland in the european commission
and good the fact that he was
caught driving his car in  the committee
in the milk in the place where it
shouldn't be at the moment it shouldn't
be it was from journalist's memory
it was just bomb what the
government needed for
the neighborhoods so I don't know why
we're coming back  there on that the readings in
fact and why the commission was at the
bottom of the hatred itself it is
taken up in this in this affair
I recall that the diplomas in which at
the time also said that gold we would like to
keep
yes in brussels we  would like to keep him
he's a very good commissioner he's a
strong politician but he does
n't have any support what you can for us if you
can refresh our memory towards
these wiretaps for me there is
no  rightly accused
i  I understand that a press article
provokes a series of two questions in the
press room but there is absolutely
nothing new under the sun
before and after the articles the article
which was published today so
with regard to this  what was the position of
the Irish government in relation to the
members of the college of
Dutch nationality is obviously
something that must be asked of
the Irish authorities for my part and on
behalf of the committee I maintain that
this does not play  role in the in the
way in which the president of the
commission
conceives the role and the mandate of the members
of her college and who are appointed for
a period of five years sometimes by a
government which changes thereafter
so sign from that moment on  we
had each time there is a
change of government or some
other business a lack of support for a
member of the college and that this leads to
his resignation we would have in fact lacked
two a few  tit lacks stability
in college I think you shouldn't
confuse two things here is
where
I run I see that he continued to
see questions at the level of our
nation
but in 2009 we said
yes to Nantes ah yes to  nantes and we
do all control vis-à-vis
our
shares
in
circulation at the caf price this file
says because of the fights that
there is also unfailing support from
all besides it says
the objective league 1 if  I'm
starting to lower
the number of press offenses by
[Music]
michelle
yes, excuse me for coming back to this, but
once again from
journalistic memory and I'm old
enough to remember that there were two more
cases I believe in the  recent history of
the european union the commission in any
case it was said watercress of which we have who
refused to resign so it
led to the resignation of the whole
commission
alas the second when it was john
dalli and so I wonder  when
Barroso  asked dali to leave
because there's no problem there
we know that he was asked to leave I
don't know if after daly asked his
friends for compensation
listen I suggest you ask this
question to those concerned themselves
it is not my role here to redo
the history of the facts and gestures each
of the former commissioners of the
European commission I want to apologize
well
I am now moving on to other subjects and
virginie I try to  his word
hello you hear me absolutely
resists summit european union
african union and this sequence whose accounts of
which we had the video or their
representatives of Ugandan
governments ignored madame van der leyen before
emmanuel macron it reminded him of
his duties of politeness of  base charles
michel assured that he had seen nothing of
the scene and that is why he
had not intervened and that he is
discussing with mac os do you
accredit this version is this  that you
have  you have the same version of things
I'm going to tell you it's something
we have absolutely not gone
back on it must be understood that
at present we have
an extremely serious situation
around ukraine
the president of  the
european commission literally works
7 days a week as well as its
close team and very, very many
members of the services of the
european commission and please believe me
when i tell you with the utmost
seriousness that our attention is
entirely monopolized by  the management of
this crisis and with regard to
protocol situations that may
or may not take place and without the least in
the world detracting from it
any situation
the fact is that our attention and the
tension of the president is on
on d  other topics for the
virginity world to a girls question
yes yes i have a follow up question
because there reports that a
similar episode happened l  the president
made a speech about it in the european parliament
where she took the time to explain
how they feel is hurt
outraged
it would not be very complicated and it
would not require a huge amount of work to
say yes indeed it is quite
possible  that charles michel does not put
seen because he was discussing with emmanuel
macron I just frankly would like it
takes two and a half seconds and I think
that for charles michel it would be a
way to clear him and if she
does not do it it is a  way to load it
less offensive than it did the
last time but but but still
offensive here is no no no is what
they have in virgin but I
completely reject this interpretation of the
way things have turned out
spoken happened the last time I
would like to remind you once again in good faith
that we have never mentioned here of
our own doing a few events,
whatever protocol incident they may be,
these are questions  So
journalists and you do your job
it's completely normal that they have
led us to take a position on the
respective roles of the presidents of the
institutions etc
honestly
the president does not load people
she absolutely did not raise the
issue  with anyone for the
good and simple for the good and simple
reason as I tell you that we
are focused on other things it
is the media who are in the process of
mounting this affair not us
who say that  there was an incident of ours
did you hear the
european commission say that there was an
incident absolutely not so thank you for
leaving the president of the
european commission out of this story
it's still the world at the  to the
world completely upside down the
president of absolutely nothing said she would
continue to do her job
as if nothing had happened she
absolutely did not speak of either president
macro or president mi  chel ni from the
Ugandan minister concerned so
frankly I think we should
avoid making a storm in a
glass of water
thank you
so are there any other questions for
us today on
perhaps more substantive subjects  yes
rihanna
[Music]
ribbons
of pandemic
[Music]
dozen
times to nothing at t
we here - andré sourgout extra and
therefore our florence
florence when you have the floor
good connection problems
thank you for seeing us there  normally
it should go
the aspiq as we say in English
press this pic
no it doesn't seem to want to work ok
it doesn't matter thank you for
contacting us bilaterally are there any other
questions for us today
I don't  I don't see thank you for
your participation and see you tomorrow